few games hold up as well as dead space
despite releasing
13 years ago visceral game's space
horror shooter is still as intense
and scary today as it was then in fact
it's shockingly good
you can get it right now on pc xbox one
and even
xbox series x with auto hdr and it still
controls it exceedingly well
features some great shooting mechanics
and looks pretty great
but most importantly dead space can
still scare the hell out of you
with a combination of great sound design
excellent jump scares
ridiculously gross monsters and awesome
set-piece moments
based on recent reports electronic arts
looked at the massive success of
capcom's resident evil 2 remake and
thought that dead space was ripe for a
similar treatment
but resident evil 2 on the original
playstation is today
realistically kind of ugly and clunky
it's a tough game to go back to in its
original form despite being full of
great ideas and frightening moments
it's the kind of game where visual and
mechanical overhaul helps bring his best
ideas forward into a modern setting
while dead space might be getting on
ears the technical leaps from the
seventh generation of consoles to now
aren't nearly as drastic as those from
the playstation 1 era
games play pretty much the same now as
they did 12 years ago
and they still look pretty damn good so
perhaps a more apt comparison
might be the resident evil 1 hd remake
in 1996
resident evil was released to the
playstation 1. later the game received
its own major upgrade with a full-on
remaster for the gamecube in 2002
at this point the game looked good
enough to not necessarily need a major
overhaul
but in 2015 the gamecube remaster
received its
own hd remaster now for the ps3 ps4
xbox 360 and xbox one it wasn't a
necessary upgrade per se
it didn't include the major changes that
resident evil 2 had
but it did do a couple of important
things for one
the game sold well incredibly well in
fact
at the time capcom announced the
resident evil hd remaster was the
company's fastest selling digital title
ever not only that but it also broke the
record on psn for opening day sales of a
digital game
in other words this was what truly set
the ball in motion for more resident
evil remakes
and while unlike dead space the
franchise has continued to have
successful titles
especially with the series reinvigorated
from resident evil 7 and now village
this was a pivotal cornerstone showing
just how much audiences wanted resident
evil games
and how much they were willing to speak
with their wallets
for two and a point i think can be
missed among those of us who grew up
with dead space and are dying for a
brand new one
that's not the case for many
up-and-coming gamers today
this was a similar case for the original
resident evil game
resident evil 1 is considered an
absolute classic amongst survival horror
fans
and absolutely still holds up today
especially the gamecube remake
but as the years pass the likelihood of
new gamers playing it drastically drops
so while these remasters might not be
something fans of the original need to
play
they can introduce an entirely new
audience to an incredible
series that also means brand new fans
along with the old
who will be excitedly awaiting a sequel
the first two dead space games are
absolutely wonderful
and in many ways the alien and aliens of
the video game world so they're games i
would love to share with a brand new
generation of gamers
a final point is that these games aren't
typically too labor intensive for the
main creative staff of a company
but can be handed off to external
studios who specialize in remakes and
remasters
just like bluepoint was able to do for
shadow of the colossus and demon souls
all in all is a relatively cheap way for
a company to assess how popular a series
is
and in my opinion could even lead to a
sequel if there's enough interest
but considering dead space is already
such a good looking game
what are some ways the game could be
remade with more than just upped
graphics
the more i think about it though the
more i think it's possible for a remake
of dead space to do wonders for the
phenomenal
and distinct franchise there are a ton
of great ideas that don't need changing
in dead space
and while a graphical overhaul would be
nice it's definitely not
essential but there's a whole lot of
room for remade dead space to expand
itself and revive the whole franchise
like yet another
unkillable necromorph through story
when it was released dead space came at
a time when games were starting to
really lean into doing some smart things
with narrative
but didn't quite have their resources or
graphical power to put that narrative on
screen
the result was and is a heavy reliance
on audio logs
this base has characters who show up in
certain places to talk with the player
character
isaac clark and they'll call out on the
radio to discuss objectives or pressing
situations
but really like bioshock and countless
others from the era
death space is a game where you arrive
after the disaster
and the only way to learn about it is by
finding tidbits left behind by the
people who are already dead
the setup is kind of fundamental to dead
space and i'm
not advocating for a change to it
although as dead space 2 showed being
caught in the middle of a disastrous
outbreak of undead monsters is just as
frightening as arriving in its aftermath
but there's a lot that could be done to
tweak despace's story and world building
to make them more clear and immediate
to pull players in deeper and ultimately
make future dead space titles more
viable
the story of the usg ishimura where dead
space takes place is one tied to the
planet ages seven
on this mining colony the people on the
planet discovered an alien artifact
called a marker
which first started working on the
colonists mines to make them hallucinate
and go
mad and eventually turned them into a
bunch of mutated undead necromorph
monsters you learn tidbits of this story
from audio logs all over the ishimura
how it arrived at ages 7 just before the
disaster how it brought the marker on
board
and how it ultimately suck them to
madness and monsters of its own
this isn't to say anything is wrong with
this type of storytelling
in fact i absolutely love how similar
stories are told where you put together
the puzzle of what happened
like dark souls however in that vein i
think more could be added to flesh out
the environmental storytelling
some of this is certainly present in
dead space but every room can tell a
story of its own of what struggle took
place there
and how that struggle took place part of
the horror of dead space is the mystery
the unknown
where's the crew what are these
creatures how do i stop them
so by presenting even more mystery
within the environment it could only
serve to boost this element
if ea chose another route we could even
see more of the story many fans don't
even know
dead space has a bunch of additional
materials that fill in the gaps of what
happened during the first game
and could absolutely expand on what's in
the dead space remake
there's a motion comic that was released
beside the game that tells the tale of
the outbreak on ages 7
and an animated movie dead space
downfall that shows what happened aboard
the ishimura before your arrival
if you were a desk based player but not
a die hard fan you've probably never
seen all of this extra material
to say nothing of the other comics and
novels that tie into the universe
so with advances in gaming tech over the
last decade plus a whole lot of
ancillary story material that already
exists
disk space could include additional
elements beyond audio logs and text
messages that showcase this
in fact there's no reason despace has to
stick with only the story of what
happens in the existing game
at all this base is actually a huge
interesting world with a lot of moving
political parts as relates to
corporations
governments in deep space and the state
of religion in the far future
they're all essential to the story that
developers have visceral told in this
first game
and its sequels despace is already a
rich world with a lot of extra story
material
and this is a perfect opportunity to get
that stuff shown on screen
and especially brought to life within
the game itself beyond the comics and
animated movie
we've seen video logs from nicole sent
to isaac so turning some of the crew's
audio and text logs
into video logs could be one way to show
more of what we previously had to read
another possibility could be in finding
surveillance footage of certain events
or even arguments this would be a good
way to incorporate more of the game's
rich lore
by showing squabbles over the game's
politics or even new ways to hint at
unitology
the in-game religion that spread
throughout the dead space universe
extra side missions could be added with
characters who somehow managed to
survive
with them relating their own experiences
of what happened
there were a couple of survivors in the
original game and we could stumble upon
a few more
perhaps one who is horrified by the
events that have unfolded so far
and can obtusely relate the player to
certain events revolving around what
happened prior to the incident
before meeting an untimely demise i
stand by desk base 1's decision not to
relate
too much of his story to the player and
its slow drip approach
as this mystery is a part of the game's
tension dead space 2 does a great job
expanding on that
but like alien to aliens the horror of
dead space 1 is in the unknown
but there are more ways that can be used
within this approach to still maintain
the game's mystery
but alternate how that story is
approached ultimately 2008's dead space
1 is already an
excellent game as is so i'll be happy to
see even a bare bones remake if that
means
introducing this series to a whole new
audience but
if electronic arts wants a horror remake
on par with resident evil 2
it has to take some serious notes from
that game as well
re2 isn't just a spiffed up version of
an old game
it's a reimagined version with changes
both subtle
and expansive to make it a better game
in many respects
it would be interesting to see what
changes could be made to expand on the
original game
and make something well worth playing
even for veterans of the original game
[Music]
you